we are moving towards a new evolution in
you know computing technology and
digital interfaces
moving away from flat framed content
towards spatial three-dimensional
content
your computer in the near future you
know it's not going to be something you
hold here it's going to be super
lightweight glasses the idea of the
metaverse is not really here yet like
the metaverse doesn't exist yet
we're building it and i do think we're
not so far on the premise of the middle
earth
what we're seeing is a leap of
understanding of
these digital spaces
and they have the potential to be very
valuable to people great experiences
start out being great before they're
mature they didn't start bad and then as
the technology progresses become good
they were good from the beginning
there's nothing like that in the
metaverse right now
[Music]
a whole virtual universe
so when you see ready player one right
that's a pretty dystopic vision of the
future of the metaverse and you know
obviously the people that are accessing
that you know vision of the metaverse
are using it through virtual reality um
they're escaping the physical world
because the physical world's not very
fun that's not the the future that i
want to see right i do think you know
from gaming perspective it starts with
gaming gaming is the on-ramp
for the reason that a lot of these
virtual experiences whether it's in
augmented reality or virtual reality
they are being created on game engines i
think games
will
unlock all the possibilities of the
metaverse will create new form of
entertainment the way games work is like
life and so
using gaming mechanics at the core of
building the manaverse
will make it more accessible to everyone
most of the activities that we do online
are going from things that you did by
yourself to things that you do
with other people like shared right so
gaming is a good example because if you
think about gaming 3d immersive and
multiplayer has been there for a long
while
[Music]
games are obviously a somewhat older
medium they started as arcade games and
small experiments by mathematicians with
something that looked incredibly basic
and pixel like pong tennis we came
through the the early console era of the
nintendos and and sega mega drives we
now have these incredibly powerful
playstations and xboxes that are in tens
if not hundreds of millions of homes
gaming has become a mainstay in in
modern society and nowadays we carry
gaming devices with us every day in our
mobile phones on our laptops people play
games everywhere and so what used to be
a kind of niche activity perhaps for
teenage boys in the 90s like me is now
about 3 billion people i think is the is
the estimate for the audience of gamers
around the world
so the video game industry is orders of
magnitude bigger than other kinds of
entertainment
and that only accelerated further during
the pandemic when people couldn't go out
to the cinema or they couldn't go out to
a rock concert and they had to stay home
and play video games but also to
maintain their social life for a lot of
children it was their only way to play
with their friends also for a lot of
more adult players and senior players it
was a way to interact with their family
with their loved ones people that would
never have played a game three four five
years ago
have now come to accept that gaming is
part of life of culture
according to a new report by accenture
the value of the global gaming industry
now exceeds given it's such a lucrative
business it's no surprise that some of
the world's most valuable companies are
now taking video gaming much much more
seriously
amazon sort of made what was seen as
quite a big move into games a few years
ago and it bought twitch for a billion
dollars but we've seen the pace of
consolidation in the gaming industry
pick up especially at the beginning of
2022 with some really monster deals like
microsoft buying activision blizzard
sony buying bungie the maker of destiny
and halo and take two buying zinger the
the social and mobile gaming company
this is some big news that's coming out
right now it looks like
microsoft is going to be buying
activision blizzard call of duty
warcraft candy crush tony hawk diablo
overwatch spyro will be joining team
xbox sony the owner of playstation is
going to buy uh bungie what's going on
here tech companies are basing their
future on games in part because of the
games themselves and the intellectual
property and the franchises that come
with that people will go out and buy the
next grand theft auto or the next call
of duty every year and it comes out but
they're also betting that we'll spend
more time in these virtual worlds you
see an evolution right now where there's
a kind of a land rush to acquire gaming
studios or gaming properties you see
microsoft acquiring activision blizzard
right that is completely completely
makes sense from the future that they
see ahead of them with web 3.0 with
metaverse today we're going to talk
about the metaverse
i want to share what we imagine is
possible
[Applause]
yeah
the experiences you'll have the creative
economy will all build and you're gonna
be able to do almost anything you can
imagine
perfect the concept of the metaverse
circulating in in gaming spaces right
where we have games such as roblox uh
minecraft where young people go on and
create worlds and have digital avatars
and and communicate through them
um what's happened last year is that
facebook went out and said it wanted to
build one
huge singular metaverse and that's
really spurred a rapid acceleration in
the number of companies jumping into the
spaces and thinking about
how we might be able to make money from
them the metaverse vision
as it was presented over the past year
by uh by facebook now meta
is a very um
not creative vision that was basically
lifted directly from matrix ready player
one it's a very old idea we talk about
the metaverse all the time but i have to
admit i don't really understand it i
don't know what it means um what do you
need in order for your games to kind of
translate into the metaverse so yes i
think i think when microsoft and
activision you know merged this talk of
the metaverse was again it's just more
marketing [ __ ] they try to make a
deal look more interesting to investors
in the month that it happened had it
happened six months before they wouldn't
have said the metaverse they would have
said something else
if there's one buzzword that i've heard
more from big tech companies over the
last few months than any other it's the
metaverse people differ in their
interpretations of what exactly the
metaverse is
the term itself is derived from a book
in the early 90s by neil stephenson
called snow crash which was actually
quite a dystopian book about society
sort of gone to hell people were using
virtual reality glasses as a form of
escape the same concept came up again in
ready player one which was a book that
was released a few years ago steven
spielberg turned it into a film
it's different depending on who you ask
sachin adella at microsoft thinks the
metaverse could be people hanging out on
microsoft teams and doing a video call
for facebook it's very much about
putting on a headset being in a virtual
world and kind of feeling like you are
really there and present with the people
around you metaverse right now is a
broad term but what it means to me is
our virtual realities that we exist in
and right now we already exist in many
metaverses when i go on my virtual
reality headset and hang out with
friends in vrchat that's a metaverse but
also if you look what microsoft has done
with the hololens and magic leap
we're seeing the foundation for
augmented reality there as well then
beyond that spatial web you know we're
starting to see websites transforming
into three-dimensional websites and
that's a whole avenue towards a
metaverse that doesn't require any
special hardware and of course video
games i mean video games are so
immersive people
you know are clocked into those for
hours upon hours on end and they lose
themselves in video games so i think
when we look at the metaverse it's kind
of the
acceleration of these technologies and
um this whole life and world that exists
only in in virtual space there is a lot
of debate about what the metaverse is
and whether there will be one single
metaverse or multiple metaverses
but the common agreement is that it's a
shared virtual space uh in which
you and i will have an avatar
that will be able to do lots of the
things they can do in the real world to
me there's only one metaverse just like
there's only one internet right there's
many domains or many websites within the
internet there's many metaverse
platforms uh you almost have to envision
it as when someone says the metaverse
it's like the metaverse capital m
and then there's maybe meta versus
lowercase m or metaverse platforms so
what does it take to be a metaverse
platform i think there needs to be an
element of social um a lot of these
early metaverse platforms have to do
with gaming right so gaming is the
on-ramp or it's kind of the parent to
that greater metaverse capital m
one thing that i find very interesting
is that it's
not something new uh when you think
about the games that we've played games
like world of warcraft or second life or
eve online are these
big video games where really real parts
of the world overlap with the digital
reality and second life people build
things themselves and then sell them to
other users but you also see it in
fortnight where people like just run
around and have fun and in games like
roblox where people can make their own
video games and
enjoy that
roblox was founded uh more than 16 years
ago by dei pazuki our ceo and eric
casell
they started doing physics simulations
so for kids or people in the lab who
wanted to simulate say cars crashing and
you cannot do that in real life so it
was easier to do it in computers but
they realized that people were having
fun creating these experiences and
sharing it with other students nowadays
it's a platform where millions of people
can come and create
3d immersive experiences
for other people to hang out share play
they can talk they can work they can
learn something new you can already like
come with your avatar into social lab
chat with other users dance express
yourself through animation and emotes
you can play both single player and
multiplayer game you can also find like
art galleries virtual museum fashion
shows dance clubs
early examples of what the metaverse can
be like fortnight or roblox where you
have lots of different people coming
together
and it's a real kind of mishmash of
different characters from different
franchises and different intellectual
properties
the problem is for games like fortnite
you can play as batman and you can play
as superman and and you can play as
characters from any number of different
movies that are coming out depending on
what the studios want to promote quite
often
but you have to do it within fortnight
and the real promise of the metaverse
and the way mark zuckerberg at facebook
talks about it is that you will be able
to take that character and go into any
game and the metaverse will be
linked in the same way that the internet
is today but in a sort of 3d kind of a
way
[Applause]
this movie scene where you see all the
characters mixed from values
movies and and brands that we are
familiar with
we have that in sandbox it's it's coming
to life we can see this merchant this
medley of content made by the community
made by users i'm mixing with snoop dogg
here care bears here smurf working that
and enabling anyone to use all of them
if you start thinking about blockchain
games and nfts
a lot of the new concepts that are
starting up in there which are small
virtual worlds like the sandbox or
decentraland these are starting from
scratch they're separate from all the
big tech companies and in those because
of the blockchain when you buy a piece
of land or a virtual object you you own
it in a way that you don't when you're
buying an object in game through call of
duty or fortnite
[Applause]
towards 2017 as we were exploring around
the new technology this time blockchain
we found the first blockchain game
cryptokitty and we experimented with it
of course and what struck us was this
idea that those virtual cats as nfts
could actually be exchanged and sold on
marketplace and that marketplace
actually being outside of the game
from there was born the idea to combine
the technology nft with user generated
content and then allow anyone to become
their own creator own nft creator
and use those nfts in a game maker so
then they could monetize their content
play with it
exchange it the way they want there's
been recent hype around what's known as
nfts or non-fungible tokens which is
essentially where you
certify ownership of a digital good
using blockchain technology so if i buy
a digital sneaker i can um sort of fuse
into the blockchain that is mine and
nobody else's and it's confirmed and so
um the suggestion is that nfts will be
used to create lots of these sort of
digital goods in these digital realms
and then they are obviously underpinned
by virtual currency and bought and sold
in virtual currency and so we see nfts
and virtual currency coming into the
space that's perhaps the long-term path
to interoperability i think it's a much
bigger ask
for true interoperability to happen
between
call of duty and battlefield which
created by electronics arts and
activision which are the two fiercest
rivals in video games equally
it seems kind of difficult to imagine
that apple which is working on its own
augmented reality headset would some way
interoperate with oculus which are made
by the same company as facebook
those companies do not like each other
and it seems like the
the vision of a metaverse where anyone
can go anywhere and take all of their
digital assets with them wherever they
go
is going to hit up against some pretty
hard business rivalries and reality
during the pandemic we definitely had
critical metaverse moments right and
they happened inside gaming platforms so
you had travis scott doing his concert
in fortnite which you know had millions
millions of views and participants he
made millions of dollars
and that was you know that was an
experiment but it was a successful one
then you had little not sex and roblox
and then you have ariana grande and
you're going to see a lot more i think
experiments inside these gaming
platforms that are you know very very
successful
so the gaming industry it is a very
important part of the future of the
metaverse right it's where a lot of
these experiments are happening but i
think fashion is really the one leading
innovation here
[Music]
gucci doing something you know in roblox
and it is valenciaga doing something in
fortnite and it's all these different
things that you see every day with
passion
one part of the metaverse that i think
does make sense is that we are
increasingly seeing people
dress up their digital avatars of
themselves online in ways that reflect
their offline personality so if you are
a big sneaker fan or if you're a big
sports fan
or if you really like a particular
character from squid game you want to
dress up your avatar in a virtual world
to reflect that
gucci came and and decided to do
something that they call the gucci
gardens on roblox right they were
creating the gucci gardens in i think it
was in florence and you needed to be
there in real life if you wanted to
attend it but they realized that not
many people can actually go to florence
and and be in that event in real life so
they did us
a replica of the gucci gardens inside
roblox and one of the cool things that
they did is that every morning they
dropped a different item and a limited
item that you could actually collect
when you joined the experience and those
limited items became kind of like
collection items that people could sell
and resell on a platform and many of
those ended up selling for more than the
cost of the real uh gucci bag which
tells you the power of of people
expressing their digital identity and
collecting these digital items and i
think that's a mindset shift i think for
a lot of people when they see something
happening in in gaming spaces or in
virtual spaces they say oh that's not
real just because it's not physical and
i think that that's the big change
that's happening is that for younger
generations the gen z and the gen alpha
what happens in these virtual spaces is
real they own these virtual assets they
build these worlds and they're very very
real to them
[Music]
i can understand why companies would be
interested in this like i understand why
like nike wants to sell you you know
shoes in the metaverse i get it and if i
could sell you stuff that isn't even
real it isn't even manufactured it's
much easier for supply chain all that
stuff of course i get it
the question isn't like is this just
more stuff for a company to sell you
like that that's easy to see the
question is like do people want this and
why do they want it and is it good is it
good for them and is it good for the
world and sometimes sure it is you know
people buy skins and decorations and you
know in fortnite and roblox whatever but
sometimes it's it's pretty bad it's
pretty harmful it's pretty addictive
i don't think we should be afraid of
this technology i mean in the same way
that when the print came out maybe
people many people may have been
concerned about it and but now we have
books and it has been amazing for
civilization that we have books in the
same way that when tv
came up books didn't disappear and
people kept reading books it's easy for
the companies to just sort of plow in
and create something and it's in their
interests to do it to create spaces that
people want to be in but i think there's
particular concern beginning to
um beginning to be raised among
lawmakers in particular around keeping
safe spaces for children so for
somewhere like roblox it's not just um
protecting children from harmful content
it's also protecting children from
predators um and and from seeing things
that
could be incredibly disturbing to them
we have tools that proactively catch
content so they can actually analyze
images or they can analyze uh different
assets and determine whether they're
appropriate or not we think about it in
a way that is flexible where people are
spending time and they're gonna use it
hopefully wisely for the things that it
does very well if you want to feel
immersed if you want to feel presence if
you want to interact this is amazing
[Music]
this is the oasis
a whole virtual universe
you can do anything
be anyone
without going anywhere at all i've seen
already
one movie i've read the snow crash book
free guy movies that kind of project the
idea of the medals and i do think we're
not so far on the premise of the medals
this idea that we can through an avatar
engage into multiple virtual worlds and
do all sort of activities much beyond
gaming or working but really like
socializing dancing interacting learning
attending all sorts of shows art
galleries museum the thing that we are
not
necessarily close to is this meta-human
representation where we think or that we
need to be as realistic as possible on
the graphic side to be immersed in a
metaverse or we need the headset the vr
headset as well
the challenge is when you put it on a
headset is having enough graphical power
in that headset because it's portable so
it has less power it has it also gets
hot so you can't get it so hot so that
it burns the person's face you know
you're in that world if you're in vr for
a long time you take off the glasses
sometimes the real world feels alien
wearing a thing on your face
and and not being able to see where you
really are or actually talk to people
and not being able to see people's real
face and being this kind of isolated and
doing everything in 3d
is not fun
or it's fun for for for certain
experiences for a few minutes at a time
there are some pretty fun vr games right
now like i like beat saber i like beat
saber well it's great i think there's
another game that i really liked uh i
think it's called you must fall you like
fight monsters with two swords it's kind
of fun you know for like 20 minutes at a
time
this idea that there's a
uh an immersive world that we primarily
experience through vr through virtual
reality
um
as sort of an alternative a substitute
you know to the real world that has a a
connected economics uh that encompasses
uh
gaming and living and working and we're
all kind of spending our time in this
like skeuomorphic 3d vr world
um i think it's dystopian i think it's
it's it's unpleasant it's stupid it has
uh pretty bad repercussions for the
world the metaverse shouldn't be a
replacement for the real world it should
help you augment the real world and what
i mean by that is that it should allow
you to do things that maybe were not
possible to do right so when you think
about the movie and when you think about
the book i mean some of the interesting
concepts there is hey can two people who
are in different geographies feel
together right feel that they are
together can they represent themselves
and be whoever they want to be that's
where you customize your avatar and then
when you are inside these worlds you
want to do different things you may want
to play a game as i mentioned but you
may also also want to listen to a
concert you may also want to do some
work right so all these capabilities are
there i just love the complete immersion
of being in a vr headset and i'm a total
vr nerd who goes into like vr chat and
alt space with my with my group of other
vr enthusiasts and we world hop and we
we hang out you know every week yeah the
hardware is clunky uh today but these
things get lighter and faster so
you know headsets are probably like at
the backpack cell phone era or the you
know the big clunky you know really with
a big antenna like that cell phone like
that's where you can maybe view where vr
headsets are today i certainly think
that right now the hardware is a still
still a little bit too cumbersome and um
for for mass adoption but we are seeing
some huge like growth in areas i don't
think necessarily people were expecting
like fitness but if you ask me from with
my business hat on which one i think is
going to be more popular no doubt i
think ar is going to be more common than
vr on a day-to-day basis because it
doesn't remove you from your physical
reality i can still be present in my
physical world while engaging with 3d
assets i think that every piece of
technology augmented reality virtual
reality they have amazing use cases and
amazing experiences for them right and
and there are situations where i may
want to wear these goggles and feel
completely immersed like i want to be
you know we're building a replica for
again let me let me pick the eiffel
tower so i really want to be
able to move around it feel that i can
touch it feel that i can move and the
technology will continue to advance so
that you have sensors to manipulate
things so that you can see things you
can see things with someone next to you
and so forth augmented reality is also
super great in the sense that
it doesn't block you from the world
around you right you are really seeing
the world around you and you're
overlaying
content information that makes that
world richer so i think that each of
these things will have its different use
cases but but it's gonna be really cool
to actually be able to enjoy these
experiences in in an immersive way but i
don't think that's the only way so we
hear a lot about the metaverse from the
big tech companies what i don't hear is
a lot about the metaverse from players
themselves this seems to me like a
vision that suits the business
objectives of
facebook apple microsoft
and epic
rather than something that players
themselves genuinely want the most
influential games in the world uh you
know minecraft you know fortnite uh
diablo world of warcraft they're not in
the metaverse
it's not that they've been the most
immersive experiences they've just been
the most creative the most imaginative
the most fun
we've had full immersion technology for
for a very long time even like let's say
with movies right we've had 3d movies
for i don't know 40 years 50 years
there's very few examples of good 3d
movies not because people didn't know
how to make them because people who go
to movies aren't actually looking for
that sort of fake immersion they're
looking for good storytelling and
sometimes the 3d really gets in the way
and it's the same thing with games part
of the urgency for
all of these tech companies to rush into
the metaverse is that we've we've really
kind of reached a bit of a plateau in
the current generation of technology
with the smartphone and the pc
smartphone penetration is is very well
established in europe and the us at this
point and developed markets and so the
upside of getting more people to
download your app is that much smaller
so tech companies are having to try and
find a new frontier to colonize and
they've seized on the metaverse as
that concept i just think that the way
it's being sold right now is very much
in line with old science fiction books
of getting beamed into a computer
um
if everything in the computer just kind
of is what you do in real life but now
you're a virtual puppet
i really see the benefit
[Music]